Imaginez qu’une soucoupe volante
s’écrase près d’un terrain de foot.
Alors l’extraterrestre sort de son vaisseau,
il essaie d’être discret ;
mais là,
un joueur de foot s’approche,
et le tire de force sur la pelouse :
« Il nous manque un joueur,
mets ce maillot et ramène-toi ! »
Mettez-vous à la place de l’extraterrestre
:
il est LE SEUL sur terre
à ne pas savoir ce qu’est le foot ;
il ne comprend pas la raison d’être,
ni l’esprit de ce jeu ;
et bien sûr,
il en ignore les règles.
Bref,
il va droit à la catastrophe
— même s’il a des pouvoirs,
il sera forcément très mauvais.
Parce que pour BIEN faire
il faut COMPRENDRE ce qu’on fait.
Si en épreuve de dissertation,
vous êtes comme l’extraterrestre
qu’on tire de force sur le terrain de foot,
alors vous allez vous rétamer.
Vous devez D’ABORD
vous poser la question :
« Qu’est-ce qu’une dissertation ? »
Si la plupart des élèves
RATENT leurs dissertations,
s’ils souffrent pendant l’épreuve
et redoutent l’exercice,
c’est tout simplement
parce qu’ils ne le comprennent pas.
Pour répondre à la question
« Qu’est-ce qu’une dissertation ? »,
je vais d’abord vous expliquer
D’OÙ VIENT cet exercice
— parce qu’il n’est pas tombé du ciel,
il a en fait des racines très anciennes ;
je vais ensuite vous dire quels sont
les enjeux FONDAMENTAUX
de l’exercice de la dissertation,
c’est-à-dire ce qu’il faut FAIRE,
en dernière instance,
pour le réussir ;
et enfin,
je terminerai par vous parler
de l’ÉTAT D’ESPRIT nécessaire
pour réussir vos épreuves de dissertation.
À la fin de cette vidéo,
vous saurez exactement QUOI FAIRE
pour progresser en dissertation.
Et si vous voulez progresser RAPIDEMENT,
je vous conseille de vous inscrire
à mon cours gratuit de méthodologie.
Le lien doit s’afficher maintenant
en haut à droite de la vidéo,
et vous pouvez aussi le trouver
dans la description.
C’est un cours par e-mail,
donc vous pouvez regarder cette vidéo en
entier,
et puis vous découvrirez ma méthodologie
après,
ou un autre jour.
Voilà voilà,
on peut commencer.
Première chose :
pour réussir l’exercice de la dissertation,
vous devez savoir D’OÙ il vient.
Écoutez bien ce que je vais vous dire
et la dissertation n’aura plus de secret
pour vous.
Je vais vous raconter rapidement
l’histoire de la dissertation.
Écoutez bien,
parce que ça va vous permettre de comprendre
L’ESPRIT de l’exercice
— et ça,
comme je vous l’ai déjà dit,
c’est crucial pour le réussir.
Alors,
d’où ça vient,
la dissertation ?
Les origines les plus anciennes,
ce sont des techniques oratoires de l’Antiquité.
Vous connaissez les sophistes ?
C’étaient des profs itinérants
qui sont devenus célèbres à Athènes,
à peu près à la même époque que Socrate.
C’étaient surtout des profs de rhétorique,
c’est-à-dire qu’ils enseignaient l’art
de persuader par la parole.
Et leur enseignement est une racine de l’exercice
de la dissertation
parce qu’ils apprenaient à leurs élèves
à examiner une question
SOUS TOUS les angles.
L’objectif,
c’était de les rendre capables de défendre
N’IMPORTE QUEL point de vue
— le pour,
le contre,
ou même des positions intermédiaires.
Là,
je pense que vous voyez le rapport avec la
dissertation :
quand on disserte,
on réfléchit à une question
en partant du principe qu’on ne connaît
pas la vérité
— on va DÉCOUVRIR la vérité,
ou plutôt s’en approcher,
au fur et à mesure qu’on réfléchit.
Il y a même une technique des sophistes
qui est à l’origine du fameux plan
« thèse, antithèse, synthèse » :
c’est la technique dite
des « discours doubles ».
Elle consiste à soutenir successivement
deux points de vue opposés,
c’est-à-dire à peser le pour et le contre,
toujours dans l’objectif de s’approcher
de la vérité.
Cette technique des « discours doubles »,
elle est liée à une autre origine historique
de l’exercice de la dissertation,
la DIALECTIQUE des philosophes.
La dialectique,
en pratique,
c’est un échange méthodique de paroles
entre deux interlocuteurs.
Vous savez,
c’est la manière dont Socrate dont parlait
à des mecs :
on lui disait un truc,
et il répondait
« Ah mais tu crois vraiment ? »
— l’autre rebondissait,
et la conversation progressait comme ça,
de rebondissement en rebondissement.
Là encore,
je pense que vous voyez le rapport avec la
dissertation :
votre raisonnement doit progresser
de position en position,
et chaque position doit naturellement entraîner
la suivante.
En fait,
la dissertation SIMULE
une conversation entre deux personnes intelligentes,
qui examinent une question
avec une certaine ouverture d’esprit.
Voici pour les origines ANCIENNES
de l’exercice de la dissertation,
maintenant je vais évoquer rapidement
deux origines plus récentes.
La première,
c’est l’enseignement de la rhétorique
dans les facultés du Moyen Âge.
Comment ça se passait ?
Eh bien,
on débattait à propos d’un auteur
devant un auditoire :
c’est ce qu’on appelle la DISPUTATIO,
qui veut dire « examen, discussion ».
Cette racine de l’exercice de la dissertation,
elle révèle l’importance de
l’ARGUMENTATION :
vous écrivez une dissertation
pour CONVAINCRE,
pour PERSUADER
— il y a les deux dimensions.
Seconde origine récente de la dissertation
:
en France,
c’était l’exercice de recrutement des
profs,
au dix-neuvième siècle.
Elle est devenue une épreuve du Bac
en 1864,
mais avant on la pratiquait
surtout dans les meilleurs lycées parisiens,
pour préparer les élèves aux concours.
À partir de là,
la dissertation s’est étendue aux autres
disciplines
— histoire, droit, économie, et caetera
—
puis elle s’est imposée comme l’exercice
par excellence
des futurs CADRES du pays
(dans la fonction publique,
les professions libérales et intellectuelles).
Pourquoi est-ce qu’il est utile
de connaître cette origine ?
Parce qu’elle révèle que la dissertation
est
un exercice DIFFICILE,
autrefois réservé à une ÉLITE intellectuelle.
C’est ce que je rappelle aux élèves qui
m’écrivent
« Romain, je comprends pas,
j’ai lu tous tes articles de méthodologie,
mais je suis pas passé de huit
à dix-huit ! ».
En dissertation,
vous n’allez pas passer de huit
à dix-huit
du jour au lendemain,
parce que c’est un exercice difficile
qui demande de se préparer avec soin.
Et en particulier,
vous devez connaître
et maîtriser
les enjeux
FONDAMENTAUX
de l’exercice.
Il y a tellement d’élèves
qui me demandent mon avis
sur des points de détail :
« Romain,
il faut mettre le numéro des parties
entre parenthèses
dans l’annonce de plan ? » ;
« Romain,
il faut des questions dans les transitions
? » ;
« Romain,
c’est une bonne idée
d’utiliser cette référence ? »
« Romain,
tu es sûr qu’il faut sauter une ligne
avant l’annonce de plan ? ».
Je réponds toujours la même chose :
faites bien la différence
entre L’ESSENTIEL
et l’ACCESSOIRE.
Parce que si vous vous focalisez sur des détails,
c’est-à-dire sur l’ACCESSOIRE,
alors vous perdez probablement de vue
l’ESSENTIEL.
Or pour réussir votre dissertation,
il vous SUFFIT
de réussir l’ESSENTIEL.
« Est-ce que c’est essentiel
de préciser le numéro de la partie
dans l’annonce de plan ? »
Bien sûr que non.
« Est-ce que c’est essentiel de citer
tel ou tel auteur ? »
Il peut y avoir des exceptions,
mais très généralement
NON.
Regardez par exemple ce que dit
le rapport du jury de HEC de 2018 :
« La présence de telle ou telle référence,
dans une copie,
n’a aucune valeur en soi,
pas plus que le nombre de citations :
seule compte la PERTINENCE
de l’usage qui en est fait
dans le cadre d’une argumentation suivie.
»
Donc pour savoir
CE QU’EST une dissertation,
et pour réussir cet exercice,
il faut se demander :
qu’est-ce qui est ESSENTIEL
en dissertation ?
Eh bien je vais vous le dire.
Il y a DEUX enjeux fondamentaux en dissertation
:
premier enjeu,
la réflexion ;
second enjeu,
l’expression.
Pour réussir une dissertation,
vous devez réfléchir
et vous exprimer efficacement.
Pour être plus précis,
disserter,
ça consiste à
RÉSOUDRE
un PROBLÈME intellectuel.
Et vos éléments de résolution,
vous devez les présenter clairement,
et vous devez CONVAINCRE votre lecteur,
c’est-à-dire le correcteur,
qu’ils sont pertinents.
Alors bien sûr,
vous devez aussi avoir un minimum de connaissances,
mais ça n’est pas du tout la priorité,
parce que la dissertation n’est PAS
un contrôle de connaissances.
Plein d’élèves qui connaissent leur cours
sur le bout des doigts
se RAMASSENT en dissertation ;
et inversement,
il n’est pas rare que des élèves CARTONNENT
avec peu de connaissances
— c’est juste qu’ils réfléchissent
et s’expriment efficacement.
Voilà,
vous n’avez pas besoin d’en savoir plus
:
oubliez donc les détails ;
réfléchissez efficacement au sujet,
écrivez clairement,
et vous allez cartonner.
Enfin,
c’est PRESQUE sûr,
parce qu’il y a encore une chose
que vous devez savoir
sur l’exercice de la dissertation.
Pourquoi est-ce qu’il y a des dissertations
partout
dans le système scolaire français ?
Eh bien parce que c’est un exercice BIEN
PRATIQUE,
qui permet de tester plusieurs compétences
à la fois
— ça revient,
comme je viens de vous le dire,
à la réflexion
et à l’expression.
Mais pourquoi est-ce que je vous dis ça ?
Pourquoi est-ce que je me positionne
DU POINT DE VUE
du système scolaire ?
C’est pour vous encourager à être
PRAG-MA-TIQUE.
Vous ne rédigez pas un article ;
vous n’écrivez pas un essai de philosophie,
d’histoire,
d’économie,
ou de droit ;
vous faites SIMPLEMENT
un EXERCICE
qu’un prof corrigera
en quelques minutes.
Autrement dit,
la dissertation est un exercice SCOLAIRE.
Je répète pour que ça rentre :
De cette vérité,
vous pouvez tirer TROIS conséquences pratiques.
Première conséquence :
comme le système scolaire récompense
les BONS ÉLÈVES,
vous devez simplement montrer
que vous en êtes un.
Votre objectif,
c’est UNIQUEMENT
de faire
un BON devoir d’école.
Contentez-vous donc de suivre les règles
du jeu
du mieux que vous pouvez.
Deuxième conséquence
du fait que la dissertation
est un exercice scolaire :
ne cherchez pas à être ORIGINAL ;
n’essayez pas d’impressionner le correcteur,
parce que votre texte ne l’intéresse pas
et ne lui apprendra rien.
Troisième conséquence,
qui découle des deux précédentes :
travaillez comme un BON élève,
préparez-vous avec soin,
mais de manière TRÈS PRAGMATIQUE !
Les élèves qui cartonnent en dissertation
sont les plus pragmatiques.
Ils ont démystifié la matière,
l’épreuve,
et la notation.
Ces élèves connaissent très bien les règles
du jeu
et ils travaillent UNIQUEMENT
pour la note.
C’est une vérité qui dérange,
mais le BUT de l’exercice de la dissertation,
c’est bien d’avoir
LA MEILLEURE NOTE POSSIBLE.
Et si vous voulez décrocher la meilleure
note possible,
inscrivez-vous à mon cours gratuit
de méthodologie par e-mail.
Le lien doit s’afficher maintenant
en haut à droite de la vidéo,
mais vous pouvez aussi le trouver dans la
description.
Alors,
qu’est-ce que vous devez retenir de cette
vidéo ?
Première chose :
la dissertation est un exercice DIFFICILE
qui était autrefois réservé
à une élite intellectuelle.
Ne croyez donc pas
que vous allez réussir une dissertation
parce que vous avez lu votre cours pendant
deux heures.
Deuxième chose à retenir :
les deux enjeux de la dissertation,
ce sont la réflexion
et l’expression (écrite).
Ne confondez pas l’exercice de la dissertation
avec d’autres exercices :
ce n’est pas un contrôle de connaissance,
un commentaire,
ou encore un résumé.
Le BUT de cet exercice,
c’est d’évaluer votre capacité
à RÉFLÉCHIR à une question complexe
et à vous EXPRIMER efficacement à l’écrit.
Enfin,
troisième et dernière chose à retenir :
restez SCOLAIRE.
Voilà,
maintenant vous savez
CE QU’EST une dissertation.
Vous avez posé les bonnes fondations
pour réussir vos prochaines épreuves.
J’espère que cette vidéo vous a plu,
et qu’elle vous sera utile.
Si vous avez des questions,
n’hésitez pas à laisser un commentaire.
Et puis souvenez-vous
que vous n’avez pas besoin de vous prendre
la tête
pour réussir une dissertation.